the short sm7 is a legendary microphone
hell it was used in most of Michael
Jackson's tracks Thriller to name one of
them
used by many sound engineer Studios and
as of late streamers and podcasters
definitely not forget the new musicians
like my friends who have used this exact
sm7 that I bought from my friend Russia
[Applause]
for so long it might as well be a family
heirloom at this point one thing that
many new users streamers and podcasters
didn't realize when getting an sm7b is
that one you'll need an audio interface
to get this to even work and if you're
looking for one to kick things off check
out the amount of streaming bundle
review I did here
somewhere there many companies saw this
as an opportunity to onboard a lot of
you out there with USB plug and play
microphones like the Sennheiser profile
mic the Blue Yeti and Razer serum V2 Pro
the other fact is that you require plus
60 decibels of Clean Gain in order to
get the results many are familiar with
that reason alone brewed up the need for
aftermarket preamps like Cloud lifter or
audio interfaces with preamps by
companies like focusride so this is the
sn7 DB and though it isn't Plug and Play
like the other microphones I mentioned
it alleviates the need for an
aftermarket preamp by having one already
built inside for the uninitiated the
Shure sm7 Isa mic with a reputation for
being one of the most widely used
microphones for recording Engineers
since the 70s and the sm7b that I have
here has become an industry standard
since the 2010s Infuse the original
Engineers of the product could hardly
dream off this series of dynamic
microphones was designed to focus on a
singular Sound Source your voice or in
this case mine and it has Faithfully
delivered a warm broadcast sound for
years with that little history let's sit
all the way let's take it out the box
you got a nice little sure sticker here
safety precautions don't need that
you've got the band for cable management
you have a bigger filter here you have
it adapter for different threadings here
last but not least definitely not least
it's the
sure
sm7de take a quick look at the back of
these and you realize instantly that
they are not the same and also I mean
like the name is like right there really
quickly explaining the functions of each
switch the first switch is for high pass
filter and low cut the one on the right
the second switch affects the mid
frequency for the most part a lot of us
just stick with not adjusting those at
all so the main difference between the
sm7b and the sm7db specs is that now you
don't need a flat hit for that anymore
they are proper switches you can just
use your finger and just flick up and
down
there's also a switch for bypass over
here and of course the pre-m option on
the sm7db for 18 decibels or 28 decibels
so besides all that are the options for
the plus 18 decibels or 28 decibels
which is the custom preamp sure has
prepared so the output is boosted for
you or even getting a separate preamp
which would cost quite a bit if you're
buying one of those alongside an ss7b
we're going to be doing a small test of
the sm7 DB right now alongside the sm7b
at the same time we'll be mounting the
sm7db
microphone arm for the folks at Sea here
live if you like what you see check them
out Link in the description below
we'll be running the sm7b and the sm7db
on this here
fantastic microphone arm I mean great
dude it comes with an XLR cable like I
don't see that often this is how the
Shure sm7b sounds like and nothing has
been altered besides that this is how it
sounds like so now we have the sm7db all
set up on this microphone arm and we are
currently on 18 plus decibels and it
sounds pretty good I mean come on it's
an sm7b essentially with a Now with an
inbuilt preamp and we'll be switching
over to 28 decibels let's just do that
and
all right so this is how the sm7db
sounds like with 28 decibels and I'm
liking what I'm hearing I mean I'm it's
well I love this bike man so now that
sure is basically just putting a preamp
in this thing I think it's doing great
but obviously you know if you don't want
the preamp in there and still want that
classic sm7b functionality ish ish you
can just bypass the preamp we should be
doing right now
so you essentially get this and you know
add in that plus 60 decibels of LA
clingyan and all that kind of stuff I
don't know you sound Engineers you all
know what you're doing so
but basically this is how it sounds like
and now we're going to turn that bypass
off
[Music]
and yeah
so we're back in at 20 decibels and I
think I'm going to be keeping this at 20
decibels before we get into the next
segment this channel is supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stay around for
this sponsored message
Usain Bolt 14x OLED it features a large
70 watt hour battery and stunning Nano H
14.5 inch 2.8k 120 hertz OLED display
powered by the latest 13th gen Intel
Core I9 CPU and RTX 3050 GPU all packed
in a thin 16.9 mm chassis that only
weighs 1.5 kilograms so you can stay
focused at work or play for more
information check out asus.com
so with that test out the way let me
know what you think in the comments
below and if you like what you're
hearing so far check out our other
videos maybe leave a like And subscribe
to us hopefully but yeah carrying on a
lot of companies out there will usually
sell their newer microphones in bundles
with boom arms to make it more
attractive for newer buyers but I kind
of wish since Shure is targeting the
podcast the streamer Market bundle it in
at the very least with a stand because
in no way are stands expensive and like
the majority of streamers and podcasters
and vocalists I know however as someone
that doesn't have a mic stand on hand at
home the only way I can describe getting
this out of the box for a newer customer
would be how a child would purchase a
certain 40 000 warhammers box of models
thinking they would all be assembled and
painted and yeah it's not that fun of
course this isn't mental children but it
wouldn't hurt to you know have a
functional setup all in one box as a
newer buyer getting the sm7 DB you know
just just get a mic stand or a
microphone on like this one because you
only see that they're not that expensive
depending on what you want out of the
microphone arm or stand but for the most
part yeah they're pretty affordable for
the potential podcasters and streamers
or even veterans looking to finally
upgrade what they have currently the
question on your minds probably would be
is it worth the money to upgrade if you
want to sound exactly like what you're
hearing throughout the entire video get
it it will save you money on getting a
separate preamp or an audio interface
that has one you just need an audio
interface that can Juice It Up with 48
volts of phantom power and your viewers
will be able to hear every line with
such warmth people might actually just
come back just to listen to your voice
as long as you don't sound like this and
of course for the music streamers out
there and just you know using people in
general sound Engineers produces bedroom
pop-up discs home studio guys yeah I
mean just everyone pretty much this
would be great for recording vocals
making up amps you know if you want to
record an acoustic guitar into this
thing for like see a music stream you
know this this obviously does the job in
mine if you're familiar with the sm7b
come on
you know this
we're gonna do a test real quick for the
benefit of the people that don't know
and just need a better idea of how it
sounds like a better mic means you hear
your mistakes more and that also means
you probably
[Music]
foreign
let me know what you think of how it
sounds like to you below and we're going
to get into our final thoughts I really
do think it's great that sure has
remedied the issue of needing a preamp
with the sn7b with this sm7 DB to make
it you know a little bit more accessible
to the newer generation and demographic
of consumers not that it was an issue in
the first place but it's nice that the
bar to work with great equipment like
this has been lowered a little bit the
sm7db is in no way a departure from its
roots but it's an interpretation for a
different time if you do own an sm7b you
can finally leave it at home or in your
office as part of your permanent setup
so if you're on the ground or traveling
a lot but have the need for a reliable
and great sounding microphone the sm7db
has you covered with that make sure to
follow us on all of our socials to get
up to speed with all the latest news and
stuff we do right here and of course
maybe leave a like And subscribe to us
it goes a long way thank you for
watching this video and if you want to
see more stuff check this out
thank you